the indoctrination of kids that is now
the purview of the left right the left
believes
again that fundamental american
principles that are taught in the home
or fundamental traditional principles
about about religion or god or
traditional sexual morays or individual
rights
all that stuff has to be taught out of
our kids as you heard
right there nicole wallace say the
dangerous thing is if parents would be
allowed to parent their children in
accordance with those old values
we have to allow the children to evolve
it's important
for the children to evolve and every so
often you see you know some pretty solid
evidence
that folks on the radical left this is
their intent they're not really hiding
it
in california as i mentioned yesterday
on the show it is written in law that
kids kindergarten through sex
are now going to be taught effectively
lgbtq propaganda
and that is not being done specifically
for
for any other reason they say that it's
about the quote-unquote safety of kids
it is not about the safety of kids
there are ways to protect kids from
bullying that do not involve teaching
lgbtq
radical propaganda that is not what the
goal here is the goal instead
is to change the mindset and the sexual
behavior or interests or confusion
of small children that's the only reason
why you would teach this crap to
kindergarteners
you don't have to do any of that stop
bullying if you have a neutral law about
bullying in
in schools if you have neutral rules
about bullying in schools that is good
enough
and that applies to everybody regardless
of how those kids act in the classroom
but once you start teaching kids about
gender fluidity that can only
be an attempt to indoctrinate them in a
particular way of viewing the world and
to confuse them about behavior that is
all that that can be okay so there was a
video that came out yesterday
or or come out i guess a few days ago
and then it was taken down yesterday
from the san francisco gay men's square
it kind of went viral on the right
folks on the left were claiming that it
was a parody the question is what
exactly is it a parody of
so here is the san francisco gaming
squad they released this on youtube they
they did a video
titled we are coming for your children
and they say that it was tongue-in-cheek
humor but
the problem is that the statement that
they released uh doesn't really
suggest that it is fully tongue-in-cheek
here's a little bit of the video
you think that we'll corrupt your kids
if our agenda goes
unchecked it's funny
just this once you're correct
we'll convert your children
happens bit by bit quietly and subtly
we're coming for your children we'll
convert them bit by bit
right very solid stuff there in this
song
we'll convert your children yes we will
reaching one and all there's really no
escaping it because even grandma likes
rupaul
the world is getting kinder gen z is
gayer than grinder we're coming for them
we're coming for your children the gay
agenda is coming home
the gay agenda is here okay so if this
is tongue-in-cheek like we're really not
coming from your children right it's
tongue-in-cheek it's it's periodical
then why would the san francisco gay
men's choir release the following
statement this is their statement
claiming that everybody's taking this
too seriously quote the negative even
threatening responses prove that this
music and our mission are critically
necessary in today's world
many children are not being taught the
truth our message to you from the gay
community
we will continue to do our best to
counter the message of hate by teaching
young people to be tolerant and fair
it is obvious the tongue-in-cheek humor
is lost on many especially the ones
spewing death threats please take a
moment and read the entire text
we'll make an ally of you yet we are
proud of who we are we are proud of what
we sing
okay the key sentence there is our
message to you from the gay community
we'll continue to do our best to counter
the message of hate by teaching young
people to be tolerant and fair so
basically what you're saying is that the
the song
is not actually a parody what you're
actually suggesting is that
while the song is done in the mode of
parody the underlying message which is
that we wish to teach your children our
values
that part is is correct right we are
making your kids more tolerant and fair
by teaching them what we want to teach
them in schools now you as a parent may
object to this
you as a parent may say listen i wish to
teach my kids traditional sexual values
and mores
i don't want my can forget any of that i
don't want my kids like k through six
i don't i don't believe that it's
appropriate for kids who are five years
old
to have to be taught about a wide
variety
of gender fluidity and sexual
orientation questions
it's it's confusing it opposes natural
law in in the sort of traditional
moralistic sense but also in the logical
sense the the the notion
the notion of gender fluidity opposes
biology itself
like i don't think that any of this is
appropriate to be taught to children
right regard regardless of political
view it's just not appropriate for kids
but the idea here is that we are going
to change the next generation right this
is why
for example there's an entire article
recently in indy wire i think
talking about how children's animated
shows were now being stacked
with radical lgbtq propaganda content
bisexual characters in children's
animated shows
gender fluid characters transgender
characters in shows made for five and
six years olds
five five and six year olds right so the
left
has a very different vision of what
america the radical left it's a very
different vision of what america ought
to be
and the way that they are going to
achieve this is by changing
how your kids are are taught and if you
push back on them then this of course
makes you the true threat to the kids
this makes you the this again you want
to separate the country this is the
easiest way
of separating the country because as i
say i'm going to educate my kids help i
want to educate my kids
and frankly i am not interested in what
the san francisco gay men's choir thinks
my kids should learn i i don't really
care
they are not the parents of my kids they
don't know my kid's name and
they don't want what's best for my kids
i want what's best for my kids and i get
to decide that cause i'm the parent
the same thing holds true for randy
weingarten in the american federation of
teachers it holds true for the national
education association it holds true for
joe biden it holds true for all these
members of government
i get to decide how i want to teach my
kids and what i would like to teach my
kids as it turns out
is a traditional sexual morality and
traditional individual rights view
of how the government should work with
regards both race and sex
that's what i'd like to teach my kids
and if you've got a problem with that
frankly you can stick it
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content